nahed club in paris est une fête mais
richert est son prophète et suivez votre
bergère dans les catacombes de paris
entre 18 et 25 mètres des gens entre 18
et 25 ans les cataphiles sont
pourchassés par une brigade spéciale des
flics là dans ces anciennes carrières
que l'on a construit pour faire des
cathédrales les cataphiles fendu
nightclubbing y aller sans guide
c'est du suicide il parlait de la
surface une fois cogner c'est pareil au
fait
l'entrée secrète se trouve sous un pont
de chemin de fer du 14e les catacombes
c'est un labyrinthe en trois dimensions
dessiné par m6 et cher m6 pas stéphane
bande de nazes 1989 bobino change de
look
fini le théâtre un peu ringard pour
coiffeur malaise mais pas à l'aise du 93
nous avons pu y voir karen fille nue et
qui après s'être déshabillée enduite de
sperme s'est masturbé on se demande
comment une chaîne nationale que
diffuser ce genre d'image on seule
demande alors pendant que maman fait ces
cochonneries on va en profiter pour nous
annoncer quelques concerts au palace
west end girls 18 janvier à 23h france
gall indoor si que vous avez été les
premiers à voir dans l'une est le 19 à
21h au même endroit et attention 38
jeunes 20 le 26 à 20h 30 au palace il ya
un canard qu'il faut absolument vous
achetiez ces voyous à cause d'un article
super qui s'appelle comment pis c'est
quand on a la gaule
romane polanski claude challe galette
des rois aux bains les bains sont
tellement populaires qu'ils peuvent se
permettre de ne plus être vraiment
démocratique
chantal thomass
sylvie grand complexe mais qu'est ce
qu'elle peut m'arriver la voix la marée
c'est la sec sont fous
je me suis fait une galette le jour des
rois je te raconte pas soirée vague à
l'âme au gibus tous les jeudis soirs ce
qu'on entend c'est lors de nonce de
l'albatros ça c'est du hard ambiance
valstar jamais trop tard
faites y un autre canard que vous
pourriez acheter ça s'appelle perfect
est un endroit où pour y aller ça
s'appelle le palace
c'est un lundi sur deux soirées l'aube
sexy qu'on entend c'est prinz et ça
s'appelle irish open c'est ce que je me
souhaite à tous bande de nazes